you know for whatever reason society has
taught us to be turned on by six-packs
right sexy men with nice muscle this is
coming from a guy that used to lift
weights and wanted to be in a stroller
if you're a woman that have beautiful
thighs and nice legs a nice toes and
36-24-36 beautiful face oh my gosh she's
so sexy right or even when it comes down
to business or folks who are talented
who speak so well they're so eloquent
with the way they put their words
together oh my goodness this is so crazy
but behind closed doors in the world of
business I've seen so many talented
people so many folks who are brilliant
so many of them who are semi geniuses
right but behind closed door they like
one thing and that is willpower let me
tell you what I mean by willpower as
crazy as it sounds some of the most
crazy tough intense strong brutally
tough to the point that you can't do
anything to stop them or dose that on
the outside don't seem impressive some
of the most impressive people I've ever
met because deep down and said there's
one thing they don't compromise so let
me tell what that is again
willpower what is willpower here's what
will power is you'll hear a lot of times
people say no what I'm going to try to
give my best I'll give my best I'll see
what happened yeah I'm gonna try my best
I'll try to be at this thing yeah yeah
I'm gonna do my best
I'm telling you I don't know but I'm
gonna do my best we'll see I'm gonna do
my best and all this other stuff there's
always an out to their commitment yeah
but there's always an out there's always
a way to exit so flight and I don't have
to fully commit to making a work right
always then you have a small group of
people these groups of people are like
somebody go on a date with and you're
sinner you're looking at this person and
then you start talking to them and you
ask a question then you feel the depth
and you said wait a minute
that was different where is this depth
coming from you sit down with somebody
you had a lunch and there's four or five
people there new people you're meeting
one of the guys you knew one of the
girls you knew and then somebody not
talking 30 minutes later he opens his
mouth and gives us thoughts on something
and you start peeling the onion you
started layers on top of layers of wow
it's pretty intense what she just said
or he just said or you start doing
business with somebody and casually the
person's
no problem I'll get that person's phone
number two by two o'clock today two
o'clock today you get the phone number
you forgot about if she didn't forget
about it
casual you do business with somebody and
they tell you next Friday at 4 o'clock
I'll get this email to you with the 10
things you requested you forgot about it
next Friday 4 o'clock you get the email
what everything you crested and more
what happened to this person willpower
when they say they're gonna do something
they do it now the other person has
talented they sell you on this dream and
it's so amazing and it's so phenomenal
I'm gonna come through for you no
follow-through no follow-up just
gibberish just talk just looks just sexy
on the outside but on the inside
willpower Smiths and look there's a lot
of things you can lose there's a lot of
things you can compromise there's a lot
of things that's ok if you drop the ball
on it's okay if you drop the ball on a
lot of different things it's okay maybe
you're not the most eloquent
communicator speaker out there it's okay
if you're not the smartest it's okay if
you're not the brightest but it's not
okay if you say gonna do something and
you don't come through because there's
only one person it hurts when you say
you're gonna do something and you don't
come through and that's your willpower
and more and more and more your
willpower gets used to you saying things
and not doing your willpower stops
having faith and the words that come out
of your mouth and the moment your your
will power your spirit stops having
faith in the words that come out of your
mouth whatever you start telling
yourself your mind is telling you out
whatever he's not gonna do it she's not
gonna do it he's all talk she's off
they're not gonna do it no substance all
looks all sexy on the outside all
attractive but on the inside no
follow-through no follow-up no willpower
never ever put yourself in a situation
where you hurt your willpower never
because eventually the world businesses
companies families anything is ran by
leaders not because they're talented not
because they speak better than everybody
else not because they're the best at
reading books not because they have the
fanciest degree because in a boardroom
when this guy or this gal says he or she
is gonna do something you can bank it
you can cash the check baby and people
like that are not a dime a dozen
they are rarer than diamond you can
rarely find people like this and when
you find people like this you'll lock on
to them because they're going places the
market values anybody that this here
when they say something they're gonna do
they do it if you're somebody like then
you're about to work on your willpower
and it's not as good as you think it is
start small say something you're gonna
be doing do whatever you can to make it
happen make some commitments do whatever
you can to make sure that commitment
comes through stop saying I'll try my
best I'll see what I can do start saying
I will get it done
buy we will get this done by I will
commit to this and get it done by I will
we will and then come true more and more
and more you put these things together
these events together eventually you
start kind of sitting up a little bit
you're confident your eyes changing and
people start looking at your saying why
do you look at people like this why do
you have those that look on your face
it's called willpower you can call it
whatever else you want but really
underneath everything else
it's simply willpower and people who
work with that person know that that
person's got willpower once you get that
once you get that no matter what room
you're in you declare what you're gonna
be doing it looks around says listen man
if she's saying it's gonna get done if
he's saying it's gonna get them you want
to be there it'll take you places you
never thought or possible
having said that have a great week
everybody take care bye bye
you